et il n'y a pas que les produits qui
s'exportent il y a aussi les
savoir-faire nous avons fait la
rencontre de Matthieu gorge un tour enjo
qui a réussi dans le domaine de la
cybersécurité à Dublin où il s'est
installé il y a 27 ans écoutez son
interview avec Florent Clavel
bonjour Mathieu gorge bonjour vous êtes
PDG de vigieuses l'une des entreprises
leader dans le monde de la sécurité
informatique notamment le traitement des
données bancaires vos solutions sont
vendues dans plus de 100 pays à travers
le monde et vous êtes touranjo vous y
avez grandi et fais vos études avant de
rejoindre l'Irlande 27 ans maintenant
que vous êtes ici vous êtes peut-être
plus irlandais que français en tout cas
ça s'entend un petit peu ben en fait
j'ai passé le pays où j'ai passé le plus
de temps et l'Irlande ça n'est plus la
France maintenant dans quatre mois
maintenant la Coupe du monde de rugby en
France est devenue de l'équipe d'Irlande
à Tours et vous dites qu'il y a des
opportunités à saisir pour les
entreprises irlandaises bien sûr mais
aussi tout en gel notamment dans le
numérique c'est ça oui dans le numérique
en fait ce qui se passe c'est qu'à tour
il y a une il y a une communauté de
d'entreprises qui travaillent dans le
numérique notamment dans la sécurité la
cybersécurité dans la crypto qui est
assez impressionnante on pense souvent à
aller à Paris on pense souvent à aller à
Nice mais en fait au niveau de sécurité
aujourd'hui en France ça se passe
beaucoup plus à Tours la France est
organise de cette triste de cette coupe
du monde de rugby à titre elle
accueillera des milliers de supporters
irlandais notamment des chefs
d'entreprise est-ce que ça capacité à
organiser ce type d'événement sera
scruté ici en Irlande par le monde
économique irlandaise c'est pas que du
sport aussi une affaire d'image ah oui
alors le rugby en Irlande effectivement
c'est pas que du sport le rugby c'est
très business donc il y a une grande
communauté de business qui se retrouve
autour de matchs de rugby donc
effectivement
la Coupe du Monde est attendu avec avec
impatience je vous ferez du business à
Tours absolument à ce moment-là je vais
faire du business à Tours et je me tiens
vraiment à cœur en tant que tout rangé
d'origine de montrer le meilleur de la
région Touran au niveau business au
niveau accueil au niveau 20 au niveau
nourriture hospitalité et je pense que
c'est vraiment une région fantastique
que les Irlandais ne connaissent pas
forcément et j'ai vraiment envie que on
puisse faire venir de plus en plus
d'Irlandais dans la région de Tours
votre parcours est étonnant Mathieu
gorge est arrivé on l'a dit à 27 ans ici
vous étiez étudiant lea à Tours vous
êtes aujourd'hui dans la cyber sécurité
comment ça s'est fait qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé comment vous avez fait pris
votre envol alors je suis un petit peu
comme Obélix avec la potion magique je
suis tombé dedans à un moment sans
vraiment le vouloir
je vendais de la je vendais des des
cours de gestion de projet et puis j'ai
voulu changer de ville et j'étais à côté
de kilder à peu près une heure de Dublin
et je voulais venir à Dublin et j'ai
trouvé un job pour vendre des cours de
sécurité informatique et puis de là j'ai
commencé à vendre du software et
il y a 20 ans maintenant j'ai commencé
vigitroce ma propre ma propre entreprise
en cyber sécurité qu'est-ce que vous y
avez trouvé ici à Dublin quel est
l'avantage par rapport rapport à la
France notamment il y en a un forcément
si vous êtes ici alors je pense que
quand j'ai commencé donc en mon
entreprise en 2003 c'était beaucoup plus
facile d'entreprendre en Irlande qu'en
France la France a fait des progrès
majeurs de ce côté-là et le
gap entre les deux a été bien réduit
au niveau de au niveau de la de la
croissance de l'entreprise le
gouvernement irlandais aide vraiment les
petites entreprises à grandir on a aussi
un des crédits d'un crédit d'impôt pour
la recherche qui sont très faciles à
naviguer qui d'après mes informations
sont en dessous de ce qu'on peut avoir
en France mais beaucoup plus facile à
gérer et ça ça compte et ça ça compte
beaucoup ça ça compte beaucoup vous
écrivez aujourd'hui des livres ça c'est
votre autre passion votre métier c'est
presque un métier aujourd'hui c'est
presque un métier je dirais je suis très
très bien entouré dans vigitrace j'ai
une très bonne équipe une très bonne
équipe de management qui me permet
d'avoir un peu plus de temps pour faire
de la recherche et pour écrire donc j'ai
écrit un livre qui s'appelle de cyber
elephant in the board room et qui en
fait a été publié par Forbes en 2021
best-seller sur Amazon et en ce moment
je fais ce qu'on appelle des booktours
donc des tournées si vous voulez dans
les États-Unis conférences Canada en
France en Angleterre pour faire la
promotion du livre et en fait ce livre
est un livre qui est destiné aux
dirigeants d'entreprise au comité au
conseil d'administration
et j'ai essayé de traduire le cyber
risque enfin le risque cyber mais lié
aux menaces cyber on risque business un
pronostic entre la France Irlande qui se
rencontreront peut-être en quart en tout
cas à quelle équipe votre coeur balance
moi niveau rugby c'est la France
et mon fils qui qui lui est moitié
irlandais
soutient la France sauf quand la France
joue contre l'Irlande merci beaucoup
Mathieu gorge pour cette interview merci
à vous merci beaucoup